i see
uh people accusing uh
both jon jones and
israel adesanya of avoiding each other
like
like they're saying as soon as jon jones
decided i'm going up to heavyweight
then izzy came up to 205. and
and and i think that there's some other
version of it where uh
where jon jones was was uh avoiding izzy
like
i don't know there's no way i mean
there's always stupid theories like that
floating about and honestly both of them
are kind of laughable if you really
break it down because for jon jones
he was in the light heavyweight division
for the longest time a multijet
multi-generations is what he took out of
champions and contenders
one after the other see when you're the
champion of the world you're
always fighting the next best guy in the
world and that guy
being becoming the champ when you're
fighting for the title for the first
time you got an opportunity to change
your life
so you know every single person that is
fighting they're they're
leaving no stone unturned they're doing
everything they can in training camp
they're making all the sacrifices
they're spending money on on the rehab
and ev the recovery everything they can
do to be the best version
to become the champion of the world and
john jones took out as i said
generations of fighters like that one
after the other so
to suggest that he's scared of a
middleweight coming up is disrespectful
and for alasana undefeated beating
everybody
right and when you go up to another
weight class to fight jon jones
or he's fighting yamblohovich now he's
got nothing to lose
you know if he loses that fight he's
still the champion of the world at 185
and you get credit for being a badass
and trying to take on the bigger
champion
so again that that that theory for
edisania doesn't really hold any water
either
but still that's what people do they go
out there they make these theories
people that fight in the ufc they're not
scared of the other person you know
they look they might look at a match up
and think that's a bad match up
this is a good match up but scared i
don't think that's ever the right word
to use
thank you so much for watching this clip
and guess what
i have the number 30 ranked hot sauce on
all of amazon it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude